We will now consider a very
practical application of the
weak law of large numbers,
and the calculations
associated with it.
The application has to
do with polling.
There's a certain referendum
that's going to take place.
We're close enough to the day
of the referendum so that
voters have made up their minds,
and there is a fraction
p of the population that
represents the voters that are
going to vote yes.
But the referendum has not yet
taken place, and you want to
find out, to predict or estimate
what p actually is.
What you do is that you go
ahead, and you select at
random a number of people
out of the population.
And for each person, you record
their answer, whether
they intend to vote yes,
or whether they
intend to vote no.
When we say that the people are
randomly selected, what we
mean is that we choose them
uniformly from the population.
And since there's a fraction p
that will vote yes, this means
that this random variable will
be 1 with probability p, and
therefore, the expected value
of Xi is equal to p.
In addition, we assume that
we select those people
independently.
Now note that if we select
people independently, there's
always a chance that the first
person polled will be the same
as the second person polled,
something that we do not
really want to happen.
However, if we assume that the
population is very large, or
even idealize the situation by
assuming that the population
is infinite, then this is never
going to happen, and
this will not be a concern.
So how do we proceed?
We look at the results
that we got from the
people that we polled.
We count how many said yes,
divide by n, and this gives us
the fraction of yeses in the
sample that we have obtained.
And this is a pretty reasonable
estimate for the
unknown fraction p, the fraction
of yeses in the
overall population.
Now perhaps your boss has asked
you to find out the
exact value of p.
What should your response be?
Well, there is no way to
calculate p exactly on the
basis of a finite
and random poll.
Therefore, there is going
to be some error in our
estimation of p.
Then, perhaps your boss comes
back and says, OK, then try to
give me an estimate of p
which is very accurate.
I would like you to come up
with an estimate which is
correct within one
percentage point.
Can you do this for me?
Your answer might be, OK, let me
try polling 10,000 people,
and see if I can guarantee for
you such a small error.
But after you think about the
situation a little more, you
realize that there is no way of
guaranteeing such a small
error with certainty.
What if your unlucky, and the
people that you poll happen to
be not representative of
the true population?
So you come back to your boss
and you say, I cannot
guarantee with certainty that
the error is going to be
small, but perhaps I can
guarantee for you that the
error that I get is small
with high probability.
Or alternatively, I'm going to
guarantee for you that the
probability that we get an error
that's bigger than that
is very small.
So how small is it
going to be?
Let's try to derive a bound on
this probability of an error
larger than one percentage
point.
Using the calculations that we
carried out when we derived
the weak law of large numbers,
we know that this probability
of a large error is bounded
above by this quantity.
What is this quantity?
Sigma squared is the variance
of the random variable that
we're sampling.
And since this is Bernoulli,
this variance is p times 1
minus p, and then we divide by
n, which in our case is 10 to
the fourth times epsilon
squared.
Epsilon is 10 to the minus
2, so here we have 10
to the minus 4.
OK, but now, what is
this quantity?
This quantity depends on p, and
we do not know what p is.
However, if you take this
expression, and plot it as a
function of p, what you obtain
is a plot of this type.
And the maximum happens when p
is equal to 1/2, in which case
we get a value of 1/4.
That is, the variance of the
Bernoulli is, at most, 1/4.
And therefore, we obtain this
bound here where the
denominator terms have
disappeared because they're
equal to 1.
So you tell your boss, if I
sample 10,000 people, then the
probability of an error more
than the one percentage point
is going to be less than 25%.
At which point, your boss might
reply and say, well, a
probability of a large error
of 25% is too big.
This is unacceptable.
I would like you to have a
probability of error that's
less than 5%.
So suppose now that we want to
change this, and make it only
a 5% error--
5% or less.
How are you going to proceed?
Well, you have this quantity
here, this upper bound, which
we know to be less than or
equal to 1/4 divided by n
times epsilon squared, which
is, in our case, 10
to the minus 4.
We would like this quantity to
be less than or equal to 5%,
which is 5/10 to the
second power.
And after you solve this
inequality, you find that this
is equivalent to taking
n larger than or equal
to 10 to the sixth.
And then the five together
with that four gives us a
denominator of 20.
And this number is
equal to 50,000.
So at this point, you can go
back to your boss and tell
them that one way of
guaranteeing that the
probability of a large error is
less than or equal to 5% is
to take n equal to 50,000.
So 50,000 will suffice to
achieve the desired specs.
Notice that the desired specs
have two parameters.
One is the accuracy that you
want, and the other is the
confidence with which
the accuracy
is going to be achieved.
Now 50,000 is a pretty
large number.
If you notice the results of
polls, the way that they are
presented in newspapers, they
usually tell you that there's
an accuracy of plus or minus
three percentage points, not
one percentage point.
That helps things a little.
It means that you can
do with a somewhat
smaller sample size.
And then, there's
another effect.
Our calculation here was based
on this inequality, which is
the Chebyshev inequality.
But the Chebyshev inequality
is not that accurate.
It turns out that if we use
more accurate estimates of
this probability, we will find
that actually much smaller
values of n will be enough
for our purposes.